[Música]
crece la atención entre Perú y Colombia
la presidenta Dina boluarte cargó contra
su homólogo colombiano Gustavo Petro y
le pidió que se dedique a gobernar su
propio país esto luego de que el
congreso peruano declarara persona no
ingrata al jefe de estado colombiano
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador firmó el decreto que
nacionaliza el litio en ese país
Establece que sólo una nueva empresa
Pública denominada litio para México
podrá explotar el mineral se trata del
elemento clave para la fabricación de
baterías
en Brasil late el carnaval 2023 la gran
fiesta ya se vive en Río de Janeiro
donde millones de cariocas salieron a
las calles para celebrarlo sin
restricciones por el Coby 19 por primera
vez en dos años hasta el 25 de febrero
la ciudad se inunda de música baile y
colores
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
América Latina porque crece la atención
entre los gobiernos de Perú y Colombia
la presidenta peruana Dina boluarte
cargó contra Gustavo Petro y le exigió
que se dedique a gobernar su propio país
esto luego de que el congreso peruano
declarara persona no grata al mandatario
colombiano un fuerte crítico del manejo
de la crisis social en Perú ampliamos en
el informe
la atención entre Perú y Colombia ha
escalado hasta el punto que el viernes
el congreso peruano declaró persona no
ingrata al presidente Gustavo Petro el
punto de la discordia un comentario del
mandatario colombiano criticando la
acción policial peruana en las protestas
contra el gobierno en Perú los policías
marchan como nazis contra su propio
pueblo rompiéndola convención americana
de los Derechos Humanos la medida contra
Petro que ha apoyado al expresidente
Pedro Castillo desde que salió del Poder
y no ha reconocido a Dina boluarte como
presidenta prohíbe el presidente de
izquierdas volver a pisar Perú e implica
un quiebre en las relaciones bilaterales
entre Colombia y Perú yo desde acá le
digo al señor Petro que yo que se
dedique a gobernar Colombia que también
sus calles están llenando de protestas y
que nos deje a nosotros los peruanos
resolver las nuestras no obstante pese
al enfado de Lima el presidente
colombiano no ha sido el único que ha
señalado comportamiento sin apropiados
por parte de la policía peruana en el
marco de las manifestaciones que exigen
elecciones anticipadas y la división de
Dina boluarte en el país andino amnistía
internacional acusó a las autoridades de
hacer un uso ilegítimo de armas contra
civiles
con un sesgo racista y clasista
especialmente contra los indígenas el
número de muertes arbitrarias por la
represión estatal se encuentra
concentrado de manera desproporcionada
en regiones con población
mayoritariamente de pueblos indígenas
por el mismo motivo el gobierno de Perú
también ha tenido tensiones con otros
países de la región como México o
Bolivia en la región de sucumbíos en
plena selva amazónica ecuatoriana
todavía quedan los vestigios de la
actividad petrolera de tres décadas de
la empresa estadounidense Texaco algunos
pozos cerraron y empezó una ardua
batalla judicial por la limpieza de la
zona pero en la actualidad activistas y
comunidades locales siguen reclamando
justicia ambiental luego de verse
afectados por la contaminación y la
pobreza más detalles en el informe
oro verde por oro negro en pleno corazón
de la amazonía ecuatoriana la extracción
de petróleo por parte de la empresa
estadounidense texacoral durante décadas
cambió la vista para siempre algunos de
los más de 300 pozos ya cerraron pero el
paisaje todavía está lleno de oleoductos
camiones cisterna y refinerías Texaco lo
que hizo fue aquí en la amazonía
ecuatoriana causar un desastre ambiental
por su ambición económica sin respetar
la vida de quienes vivimos acá para los
habitantes de la región así como para
los expertos la industria petrolera en
la zona ha sido sinónimo de pobreza y
contaminación llegándose a verter unos
60 millones de litros de líquidos
nocivos durante la época de actividad lo
que terminó afectando a la salud de
campesinos e indígenas que habitan en la
zona existe un 130% más de desarrollo de
cáncer
un 111% más de infertilidad y un 150%
más de abortos la pelea judicial de más
de 30 años para asumir responsabilidades
del desastre natural terminó
involucrando a altos tribunales
internacionales pero todavía hoy no hay
solución para las comunidades locales
que apelan a la concienciación y a no
dejar en la lucha Cuál es la esperanza
la lucha social entender el rol que
juega la amazonía en el equilibrio del
clima en el mundo y defenderla en
paralelo el gobierno de Guillermo lasso
apostó por redoblar las actividades
petroleras en las zonas en activo con el
objetivo de extraer un millón de
barriles diarios
el presidente de México Andrés Manuel
López Obrador firmó un decreto con el
que se nacionaliza el litio y se tendrán
que entregar todas las reservas del
mineral a la secretaría de energía con
la medida se declaran como zona de
reserva
234.855 hectáreas el mandatario recordó
que el litio es la materia prima básica
para la elaboración de baterías para
automóviles eléctricos entre otros usos
nacionalizar el litio para
no lo puedan
explotar
extranjeros Ya se tomó la decisión la
ley está aprobada en el poder
legislativo y el litio es de la nación
Hablamos ahora de Brasil porque del
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula Silva se
enfrenta a una problemática compleja y
es las armas de fuego en manos de
particulares antes de que ya ir
bolsonaro llegara al poder la cifra era
de uno coma tres millones cuatro años
después el número se acerca a las tres
millones de armas según dos ong
previamente conversamos con Darío
pignotti analista político y
corresponsal en Brasil de la agencia
italiana danza que nos explicó qué tan
lucrativo es el negocio de las armas en
Brasil y que tantos problemas tendrá
Lula al oponerse
igual que ha ocurrido en Estados Unidos
ustedes saben el gobierno del
expresidente bolsonaro tomó como como
referencia como ejemplo varias de las
medidas de poder del gobierno de Donald
Trump el lobby armamentístico en Brasil
es muy poderoso y también el lobby
social y el lobby el lobby legislativo
tanto que no solo hay en el en la cámara
de diputados el bloque de La bala así
llamado compuesto por ex militares y por
policías y ahora surgió un nuevo bloque
parlamentario el de los cazadores y
coleccionadores que son una escena por
tanto si unimos el poder económico y su
capacidad entre comillas de fuego más El
poder legislativo no será Tan sencillo
para el presidente Lula que no cuenta
con un buen con buena presencia con
mayoría ni en la cámara de diputados ni
en el senado
revertir o hacer frente a este insisto
un poder legislativo y económico muy
fuerte en favor de estos millones de
aparentes cazadores y coleccionadores y
seguimos en Brasil donde arrancó el
carnaval en Río de Janeiro millones de
personas salieron a las calles para
festejar el evento sin restricciones por
el covid 19 por primera vez en dos años
Ahora las escuelas de samba o blocos
competirán durante una semana por
convertirse en los ganadores de este
2023 Alba Santana nos cuenta cómo fue el
inicio de esta fiesta
declara el carnaval de la Democracia el
carnaval de Río de Janeiro abierto
[Aplausos]
así el rey momo personaje principal del
carnaval dio inicio al más famoso del
mundo el de Río de Janeiro
tras dos años con restricciones debido a
la pandemia de covid-19 este 2023 los
cariocas han vuelto con toda
[Música]
con los cuerpos llenos de purpurina
disfraces coloridos y mucha Samba en la
ciudad de maravillosa también celebran
otra importante Victoria para muchos la
salida del ultraderechista Jair
bolsonaro del poder
[Música]
este año los organizadores del evento
han intentado poner en relieve el papel
de los ciudadanos afro protagonistas
indiscutibles de la fiesta y maestros de
los ritmos de la zamba
desde el viernes en la noche hasta el 25
de febrero el sambódromo y las calles de
Río de Janeiro estarán inundados por
música y gente hasta el amanecer una
fiesta por la que gente de todo el mundo
se ha desplazado hasta la ciudad
brasileña somos dos gays franceses
en Río estoy disfrutando de la vida
lavamos este país amamos a las mujeres
es increíble Gracias río creo que es uno
de los mejores días de nuestras vidas
[Música]
Ríos increíblemente bonito la naturaleza
la diversidad de barrios el carnaval es
una locura
la alcaldía carioca Calcula que recibirá
cientos de miles de personas durante el
carnaval buenas noticias para la
economía de la ciudad que se espera que
recaude cerca de mil millones de dólares
tras más de una semana de bailes y
felicidad
fin del informativo gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]